la reacción de eliminación de dos es una
reacción exterior específica y eso lo
que significa es que la estéreo química
del sustrato determina la estéreo
química de los productos y eso se debe
al mecanismo de reacción en este vídeo
para que no se vuelva muy largo vamos a
suponer que estás muy bien familiarizado
con los mecanismos de reacción de dos
las proyecciones de newman y las
proyecciones en perspectiva así es que
el carbono que está enlazado con el
bromo es el carbono alfa y el carbono
enlazado con el carbono alfa es el
carbono beta y sabemos que en el
mecanismo de reacción de dos una base
fuerte va a llegar y se va a llevar a
este protón a un protón beta entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es ver en esta
dirección la dirección del enlace si
ponemos nuestro ojo en este lugar y
vemos hacia la molécula en esta
dirección lo que obtenemos es la
proyección de newman y por acá
el grupo metilo está arriba a la derecha
es este grupo metilo por acá y el
hidrógeno está arriba a la izquierda así
es que es este hidrógeno
nuestro grupo fenil los encuentra hacia
abajo y recuerda un grupo fenil o es
simplemente un anillo vencen y ccoo y
luego podemos empezar con nuestro
carbono alfa por aquí tenemos un átomo
de bromo que está abajo a la derecha y
lo tenemos por acá sabemos que este
carbono alfa también tiene otro átomo de
hidrógeno que se encuentra abajo a la
izquierda lo podemos ver aquí y luego
tenemos otro grupo feng y lo que se
encuentra hacia arriba ahora nosotros
sabemos que para que pueda suceder la
reacción de dos necesitamos tener un
hidrógeno en posición anti peri planner
al átomo de bromo y si nos podemos
observar esta proyección de newman
podemos ver que ya tenemos ese átomo de
hidrógeno en posición anti peri planar
con el átomo de bromo
si es que ya tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos para que se pueda realizar
el mecanismo de reacción de dos por aquí
a la derecha tenemos otra vez la misma
proyección de newman lo único es que la
rote un poco para que tengamos esta
línea entre el hidrógeno el bromo y los
dos carbonos en forma vertical y que
todo sea más fácil de entender pero son
exactamente la misma proyección de
newman así es que este hidrógeno es este
hidrógeno este grupo metilo es este
grupo metilo por acá
el grupo fenil o los seguimos teniendo
nada más que está un poquito para acá
todos esos son los grupos enlazados con
el carbono beta y ahora vamos con los
que están enlazados con el carbono alfa
ahora el átomo de bromo lo estamos
colocando abajo
el grupo fenil o se encuentra a la
derecha y el hidrógeno está por acá y
listo así es que es la misma proyección
de newman sólo que ahora el hidrógeno
que está en posición anti peri planar
con
y el bromo se encuentran en este plano
vertical y de hecho podríamos dibujar
nuestro producto directamente a partir
de esta proyección de newman tenemos por
aquí nuestra base fuerte que llega y se
lleva a nuestro protón beta los
electrones del enlace de ese protón se
quedan entre los dos carbonos para
formar un enlace doble y al mismo tiempo
estos electrones se van con el bromo
para formar una unión bromuro y podemos
dibujar el producto directamente a
partir de esta proyección de newman y es
justo lo que vamos a hacer lo primero
que tenemos que observar es que aquí
este grupo fenil y este grupo metilo se
encuentran del mismo lado del mismo al
lado del doble enlace entonces si
tenemos por aquí nuestro doble enlace
como podemos ver por acá
el grupo fenil y el grupo metilo se
encuentran del mismo lado del doble
enlace y del otro lado del doble enlace
tenemos este otro grupo fenil o y este
entonces en el carbono de atrás tenemos
este hidrógeno y en el carbono de
adelante tenemos este otro grupo fenil y
este es el producto de esta reacción
puede ser un poquito difícil verlo todo
desde la perspectiva de la proyección de
newman entonces vamos a volver a verlo
en una proyección en perspectiva vamos a
volver a decir cuáles son todas estas
moléculas
este es el carbono alfa
este es el carbono beta y llega a una
base fuerte y se lleva a uno de estos
protones los electrones de este enlace
se pasan para acá para formar un doble
enlace y al mismo tiempo los electrones
de este enlace se van con el bromo y
otra vez el grupo metilo y el grupo
fenil o se quedan del mismo lado del
enlace doble los tenemos por acá del
mismo lado y del otro lado del enlace
tenemos este otro grupo fenil y este
hidrógeno que se quedan del mismo lado
del enlace
entonces nuestros grupos fenil o están
de lados opuestos del enlace doble y por
lo tanto este es el al que no es bueno
vamos a ver un vídeo acerca de todo lo
que acabamos de hacer para que quede un
poquito más claro por acá los grupos
morados son los grupos feng y los el
rojo es el bromo y en este carbono
tenemos un grupo metilo saliendo hacia
nosotros y un hidrógeno que se está
alejando de nosotros vamos a ver esta
molécula en la dirección de este enlace
y eso nos va a dar la proyección de
newman por acá tenemos la proyección de
newman y aquí como podemos ver ya
tenemos a este hidrógeno en posición
anti peri planar con el bromo lo podemos
rotar un poco para que el hidrógeno
quede hacia arriba y el bromo hacia
abajo pero ahora lo voy a mover un poco
hacia un lado para ver la proyección en
perspectiva
ahora vamos a pensar que llega a una
base fuerte y se lleva este hidrógeno
entonces vamos a pretender que este
hidrógeno se va se forma el doble enlace
y al mismo tiempo también se va el bromo
por aquí nos queda este al que no con
este doble enlace y podemos observar que
los grupos ven y los están en lados
opuestos entonces pues ese es nuestro
producto ahora vamos a hacer otra
reacción de eliminación de dos muy
parecida a la anterior pero hay que
tomar en cuenta las diferencias observa
que la única diferencia es la estéreo
química de este carbono la diferencia
entre esta reacción y la anterior es que
ahora el hidrógeno está saliendo hacia
nosotros y el grupo metilo se está
alejando de nosotros entonces lo que
vamos a ver es cómo cambiar la estéreo
química del sustrato cambia la estéreo
química del producto lo único que
estamos haciendo diferente es cambiar a
estos dos del lugar por acá
es nuestro carbono alfa este es el
carbono beta y vamos a poner un ojo por
acá que esté viendo en la dirección de
este enlace entre el carbono alfa y el
carbono beta y ahora pensemos en la
proyección de newman que obtenemos al
ver a esta molécula desde este punto de
vista ahora nuestro hidrógeno está
arriba a la derecha aquí en la
proyección de newman nuestro grupo
metilo está arriba a la izquierda está
por acá y nuestro grupo fenil está hacia
abajo estos son los tres grupos del
carbono de adelante y ahora vamos con el
carbono de atrás tenemos al bromo abajo
a la derecha abajo a la derecha tenemos
un hidrógeno abajo hacia la izquierda
abajo hacia la izquierda y luego tenemos
un grupo fenil o directamente hacia
arriba y listo
esta es nuestra proyección de newman de
esta molécula ahora aquí tenemos que
observar algo muy importante y es que
nuestro protón beta este hidrógeno de
acá no está en una posición anti peri
planar con el átomo de bromo así es que
vamos a tener que hacer una rotación
sobre el enlace entre los dos carbonos y
la vamos a hacer pero dentro de un
minuto
primero vamos a volver a ver esta
proyección de newman pero de una forma
más fácil de identificar que íbamos a
empezar dibujando esta línea que nos
ayuda a identificar que aquí está este
mismo grupo metilo y por acá está
este mismo átomo de bromo ok solo
rotamos un poquito la proyección de
newman pero es exactamente la misma
molécula y la misma proyección de newman
este es el mismo hidrógeno que tenemos
por acá y aquí tenemos un grupo feng y
lo tenemos el grupo metilo y luego el
otro hidrógeno el otro hidrógeno y
después otro grupo fenil o
otro grupo fenil y como podemos ver aquí
estos dos grupos ven y los siguen en
posición anti siguen en lados opuestos
pero ahora sí vamos a hacer la rotación
sobre este enlace porque necesitamos
hacer esa rotación para que el hidrógeno
y el bromo se encuentren en una posición
anti peri plana para poder realizar el
mecanismo de reacción 2 entonces vamos a
ver el vídeo ahora vamos a pensar acerca
de la estéreo química de este carbono
tenemos aquí un hidrógeno que está
saliendo hacia nosotros y un grupo
metilo que se está alejando de nosotros
si observamos esta molécula en la
dirección de este enlace tenemos esta
proyección de newman y observa que
nuestro protón beta no está en una
posición anti peri planar con el átomo
de bromo así es que tenemos que hacer
una rotación voy a rotar toda la
molécula un poquito para que se vea
mejor y ahora voy a hacer una rotación
sobre el enlace entre los dos carbonos
así en esta conformación el hidrógeno
está en una posición anti peri planar
con el átomo de bromo y observa como
ahora los dos grupos en hilos se
encuentran del mismo lado ahora movemos
la molécula y vemos su proyección en
perspectiva y desde aquí podemos pensar
que llegue a una base fuerte y se lleva
a este protón formando este doble enlace
y al mismo tiempo el átomo de bromo se
va y ahora si podemos observar el
producto que queda en el que los dos
grupos ven hilos están del mismo lado
del doble enlace bueno espero que este
vídeo te haya ayudado a entender cómo
sacamos los productos pero si por
ejemplo en un examen no puedes tener un
modelo de moléculas pues tienes que
utilizar tus propios dibujos y entonces
regresamos acá a este dibujo de nuestra
proyección de newman en el que estamos
viendo que el hidrógeno no está en una
posición anti peri planar con el bromo y
entonces sabemos que tenemos que hacer
una
la verdad yo prefiero hacer una rotación
sobre el carbono de adelante entonces
este hidrógeno a la hora de que hacemos
la rotación queda por acá y el grupo
metilo con la rotación se va para acá y
el grupo feng y lo queda dónde estaba el
hidrógeno y entonces el hidrógeno queda
arriba lo tenemos acá el grupo metilo
queda abajo a la izquierda por acá y el
grupo fenil o abajo a la derecha lo
tenemos aquí
así es que realmente no necesitamos un
modelo como el que vimos en los vídeos
para hacer estas rotaciones lo podemos
hacer con estos dibujos ya que hicimos
esta rotación ahora si el hidrógeno y el
átomo de bromo están en una posición
anti peri planar y podemos sacar el
producto directamente de esta proyección
de newman ok tenemos aquí una base
fuerte que llega y se lleva a nuestro
protón beta estos electrones se quedan
haciendo un doble enlace estos
electrones se van con el bromo
de un lado del enlace doble nos quedan
los dos grupos feng y los en esta
proyección de newman los grupos ven y
los están en una posición gosh está en
uno al lado del otro
si dibujamos el enlace doble en el
carbono de atrás tenemos un grupo fenil
y en el carbono de adelante también pero
también tenemos que ver cuáles son los
grupos del otro lado del doble enlace
tenemos un grupo metilo en el carbono de
adelante y un hidrógeno en el carbono de
atrás ahora no tenemos que hacerlo
siempre con la proyección de newman
también podemos usar la proyección en
perspectiva si lo prefieres lo tenemos
por acá tenemos una base fuerte que
llega y se lleva a nuestro protón beta
estos electrones se mueven para acá para
formar el doble enlace estos electrones
se dan con el átomo de bromo los grupos
feng y los quedan del mismo lado del
enlace doble lo mismo estábamos viendo
que sucedió por acá los grupos en hilos
están del mismo lado del enlace doble y
el otro lado tenemos el hidrógeno y el
grupo metilo del mismo lado tenemos el
hidrógeno y el grupo metilo del otro
lado del doble enlace ahora observa que
este es un al que no se está entonces
aquí tenemos una estéreo química
distinta a la que obtuvimos con la
primera reacción y de hecho además esta
es una reacción mucho más lenta que la
primera reacción y eso es porque aquí
tenemos a estos dos grupos femeninos
esta conformación en la que tenemos el
hidrógeno en posición anti peri planar
con el bromo esta no es una conformación
estable la tenemos así porque así la
necesitamos para que sucede el mecanismo
de reacción 2 pero no es la conformación
estable de esta molécula porque aquí
tenemos a estos dos grupos feng y los
demasiado cerca en posición con estos
dos grupos ven hilos son demasiado
estorbosos entonces como consecuencia
esta reacción es muy
porque esta es la conformación estable
esta conformación no es estable pero
necesitamos que la molécula se encuentre
en esta conformación no estable para que
pueda suceder la reacción de dos si nos
regresamos a la primera reacción que
vimos en este vídeo
aquí tenemos estos dos grupos ven hilos
en posición anti en lados opuestos y si
es una conformación en la que sucede la
reacción de dos porque aquí el hidrógeno
y el bromo si están en una posición anti
peri planar entonces los grupos ven y
los están suficientemente lejos como
para que ésta sea una conformación
estable y por lo tanto esta reacción
sucede mucho más rápido que la segunda
reacción que vimos aquí tenemos las dos
reacciones que vimos vamos a hacer un
resumen arriba tenemos la primera
reacción y en el carbono beta tenemos un
grupo metilo que sale hacia nosotros y
un hidrógeno que se mete hacia la
pantalla está
molécula en esta reacción lo que nos da
es un y al que no en el cual los grupos
ven y los están en lados opuestos del
doble enlace después para hacer la
segunda reacción lo que hicimos fue
cambiar la estéreo química de este
carbono nada más cambiamos al grupo
metilo y al hidrógeno del lugar y
entonces el hidrógeno está saliendo
hacia nosotros y el grupo metilo se está
alejando de nosotros ahora con esta
molécula con esta estéreo química lo que
obtenemos como producto es el zeta al
que no en el cual los dos grupos ven y
los están del mismo lado del doble
enlace y con esto estamos viendo qué
significa que una reacción sea estéreo
específica en esta reacción de dos al
igual que en cualquier reacción estéreo
especifica la estéreo química del
sustrato determina cuál va a ser la
estéreo química del producto